but i was like all right maybe he just
wants like the attention or whatever
that's when i asked him is he going up
he's like no man i'm just there to watch
jason texts that right it's like my face
and then the next one is david's face
like all happy and [ __ ] david so tonight
you know what i mean
that's what jason says he's going up
david like we're chilling like this
casual having a conversation about like
comedy whatever the [ __ ] we're talking
about
right after i show on picture tape it
was like what the [ __ ]
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast i'm your host
david soh and we have two mentally
prepared
mentally prepared mentally ill prepared
people we have patrick.t patrick.t.riley
yeah we have nick the ear the man who
spars way too hard with his friends yeah
and i have a witness here i have been
waiting to do this podcast forever you
guys are such full of [ __ ] you are full
of [ __ ]
you know what this feels like this feels
like i'm a political candidate and i'm
running for office and you guys are just
scared
that's why [ __ ] let's talk about this
politics what can i say let me tell you
something
he's been disparaging my name all over
jk news saying that every time i spar i
go way too hard i defend myself real
quick before you continue oh it's not me
that's saying it it's everyone else that
sits at the table i don't say [ __ ] i try
to defend you and alex comes here
talking about these stories about how
you beat up dylan and i'm like hey i
didn't say it alex acosta did okay yeah
let me tell you something we were uh
training on what's it called i think it
was tuesday or was it a monday
and i saw this man nick thought he
thought he was in a lumpini stadium muay
thai match
you guys are [ __ ] on my name
you tell that to the wealth on pat's
thighs
we had a moment but it's it's it's like
but that's normal you know what i mean
but the one thing we'll have i know i
could do a pat yeah we we've trained a
lot so it's okay i understand and
sometimes we go hard and it's it's
actually kind of fun but there i will
say one thing sometimes i hit you and
like i'll see your face change where
it'll be like you're like your like
mouth opens a little more and you're
like
like lower lip you're mentally prepared
that's what that is and then i know it's
like oh [ __ ] nick's about to throw it
guys pug face i'm like
then i know i know nick's about to throw
dude but i don't i don't think it's okay
no no it's manageable it's okay you
threw like the only hard shot in my head
i was that i consciously was like i'm
gonna throw a hard shot it was just a
low kick that was it because he got me
he got me on one and i was like i'm
gonna get that one back yeah and i got
it back and it's fine
but it was it was purely because of lag
all right take one get one yeah and it
was okay it was okay i'm just saying the
way he talks about himself is so
innocent like what bro what are you
talking about this is how i am when i
train i just tap tap tap tap tap i don't
know i'd be witnessing other things i
just need to back myself up all right
honestly i'm a great training partner
you gotta ask my clients you could ask
my training partners nobody helped them
because they all died
i was feeling that leg kick though for a
little bit like that until
it feels better today i probably the
next day i was like walking like ooh at
work i was like
and i had your toe imprint on my mind
that wasn't me though
we kicked each other's daughter now yeah
bro this fool got more money than me dog
that's what we're working on
i got a lot of jobs
i had a lot of jobs i never see my kid
when he becomes a world-famous stand-up
community and it's all good you know
when he becomes the next [ __ ] louis
ck except the masturbation stuff except
well maybe
hold on a second guys let's just relax
here so funniest [ __ ] thing happened
literally what was it two days ago was
it yesterday uh tues tuesday it was a
fever dream i don't know
so you guys know jason cheney right
there isn't changing
he's the only asian i know that has a
half accent i don't know what the [ __ ]
that is but he comes along it's good
branding yeah so
i told jason that i wanted to go see him
perform i was like hey i just want to
see you you know do your work just
because you know next year i plan to do
stand-up and i'm like let me just
observe
so i was like pat you down to go pat was
like yeah let's go watch him
we're in the car
and then pat i pick up pat and pat's
like hey you going up tonight i'm like
no what are you talking about i'm just
i'm just gonna watch we're having a
great conversation in the car next thing
you know this motherfucker's giggling
and then i see a video that jason cheney
sends and it is a video of my face on a
tv screen in front of the comedy club
i'm going up he's on the marquee jason
literally texts he's like guess david's
going up oh
i've talked on this podcast openly about
my crippling anxiety and i had i
specifically talked about it to jason on
this podcast and he does that to me i'm
freaking the [ __ ]
out here's the reason why
all he had to do was text me hey do you
want to do a five minute set and even if
i said no i probably would have wrote
something out just in case if i wanted
to go up that's all
that's all you have to do you're not
mentally prepared it seems like that's
what it was not even meant i had no
material
i had no material so so when you went on
stage what did you talk about
wait wait wait wait hold on let's let's
start with the story
we'll get there okay
from my point of view i'm i'm i'm
assuming i'm going up because like jason
i already think he's gonna vouch for me
and like get me a spot so i'm like all
right i'm probably gonna go up and then
i see that we're all tagged in the video
like hey long beach tonight like
harvell's
comedy show and i see david's tagged in
it and i was like okay like that seems
like dave is going to go up but i was
like all right maybe he just wants like
the attention or whatever
that's when i asked him is he going up
he's like no man i'm just there to watch
jason texts that right it's like my face
and then the next one is david's face
like all happy and [ __ ] david so tonight
you know what i mean
that's what jason says he's going up
david like we're chilling like this
casual having a conversation about like
comedy whatever the [ __ ] we're talking
about
right after i shot on picture tape was
like what the [ __ ]
starts
tripping balls
i'm sweating right now thinking about it
yeah and i was like dude i i'm laughing
hysterically like this is [ __ ]
different but then i'm trying to like
you know i actually kind of think like
you should go up so i'm like kind of
like dude just talk about you know mario
talk about anything just tell [ __ ]
stuff she's like i haven't [ __ ] don't
stand here
uh
so we get there
him and jason immediately start
wrestling because obviously there's beef
that needs to be handled yeah yeah they
started kind of tussling because that's
what needs to happen i grabbed him a
little bit i gave him a quick knee to
the gut and i ended up yeah yeah
we go downstairs david's like [ __ ] this
like i'm not going up like i'm not going
up i'm not going up so me and jason are
like trying to talk them into it being
like come on blah blah blah blah but
then it gets to the point where jason's
finally like you know what if you don't
want to go up you don't have to go up
and then uh
the club owner was talking to you two
and was like hey man just do if you want
to do two minutes if not it's cool won't
be a pressure you but we were we were
yeah he's really cool super cool
but we're trying to talk him into it
because it's like [ __ ] just you know
what he cares it's low stakes
we all think you're a superstar don't
have any material that's the thing it's
like i would have liked it if it was
like hey just go up and do whatever i'm
like cool well i did write this bit you
know that i kind of memorized a little
bit let me just try it out
i have nothing dude that actually is
really scary though because like sure i
get nervous even i have [ __ ] prepared
and i still get nervous i couldn't
imagine not doing stand-up for four
years not thinking you're going to go up
not having any material prepared and
they're like hey you're going to go up
i'd i would be [ __ ] nervous and he
told me this out loud yeah i was like
scared dude
right before you go up oh yeah you're up
now okay bro literally i would kill
myself but there was there was a point
where we're sitting at the so there's
like a little curtained off area what a
piece of [ __ ]
so david agrees david's like okay fine
[ __ ] it i'm gonna do it right so we're
like excited like okay cool [ __ ] yeah
just do two minutes whatever do whatever
the [ __ ] you want get off
so we're sitting there and like it's i
think it's um
i had gotten off stage there was a guy
after me and then it was gonna be david
so i just got off stage and i come back
talking to jason and this other dude and
then so it's like david's sitting on the
bench jason and this other dude and then
me and uh jason and the other dude are
talking going back and forth
and david is like completely in his own
head like just mind [ __ ] [ __ ]
but he's still trying to like interact
like he knows he's supposed to interact
so dave this is david literally david
said like they're talking david's like
this
and then every once in a while he looks
over and he's like
trying to be a human tripping balls dude
and i'm like that bro
i'm watching him at the corner of my i
know exactly what you're feeling and i'm
like trying not to make it known because
i don't want you to [ __ ]
dude people are trying to talk to me
right and i'm this is the craziest thing
i'm like i should have some types of
jokes blank like you're going through
your rolodex a blank page it just i was
like why don't why can't i think of
anything and people are like hey so
where are you from and then i'm like
shut the [ __ ] up
don't talk to me it's what i wanted to
say but i'm like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly
dude dude so funny but anyways he ends
up going on stage
immediately starts making fun of jason
which was a good move just [ __ ] just
get that out of the way [ __ ] on days
then he does like you did like at least
seven minutes seven to ten minutes and
it was good like he didn't he definitely
didn't bomb like he got some pretty
strong laughs and he was just going off
like tell him he talked about slapping
the dude over by the south pass fitness
gym talked about his dad and growing up
uh
he you like and you were getting good
last and it wasn't an easy room either
like it wasn't a really great story they
just give you laughs like he did good
and me and jason back laughing like what
the [ __ ] this fool is doing great like
you know what the worst part is is like
i'm watching these schools go up and i'm
like they're so professional
like look how confident they are and in
my mind i'm like i'm not going to look
like that so i'm having this
conversation in my head i'm like oh my
and you know what the thing about jason
is too he's first he started he's like
you're going to be a [ __ ] you know how
he talks and then he sees the fear in my
face he goes hey let me let me just let
me decide
he's like he's worried about you he goes
he goes all jokes aside just go up there
and talk about whatever he goes don't
worry about being good don't worry about
being bad don't even worry about the
material right now just go up there and
just talk about your [ __ ] day he goes
you've been on a podcast i've seen you
talk you can make anything funny just go
up there and just talk about it that's a
great that's great advice and each
channel said that i wanted to sock them
in the mouth yeah the stomach again huh
i was like i could literally kill you
with my bare hands if i wanted to you
stupid stupid china man
i will send you back on a boat
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then you said that on stage right
after yeah he did yeah he did he's like
i hate this chinese guy i'm gonna send
him on a boat dude it's just that that
because the i don't people don't
understand the nerves are so drastic but
what's crazy is really if you think
about it nothing bad is going to happen
at all it's just it's just it's just
your own the embarrassment is insane
yeah of course but like nothing feels
like no one's gonna kick your [ __ ]
ass you know what i mean but it's like
your soul is taking a beating but the
nerves before are just
insane because i'm sure you to this day
you should still get nervous before you
go up i do get nervous but now it's like
a nervous excitement mixture yeah but
like there's been times where i was like
that too where i like i you almost you
can't remember anything because you're
just so nervous you're like what the
[ __ ] is going on
uh so it was fun to watch david go
through that that [ __ ] is it's it's like
the the per the funny thing is too
because i told uh mariel about it right
she goes well why did you go up i was
like cause i'm not a [ __ ] yeah
this is how ridiculous like my thought
process was because i can remember now
that i'm calm everything that was going
through my mind it was it was if
anxiety versus me thinking i'm a [ __ ]
and these two sides were battling each
other hard if it was like the marvel
universe avengers
wow yeah and then i started like talking
to myself and i'm like okay if you left
tonight and you don't go up on stage
would it bother you or would it not and
it would bother me yeah it would bother
me so bad because now i'm thinking about
all this other stuff where i've said on
this podcast multiple times there's
nothing bad that's going to happen why
don't you just try it and do it now i
understand like you know
circumstantially my situation was
probably the worst thing that could have
ever [ __ ] happened
but at the same time i've been doing
stem since i was 16. i should be able to
do something right even if it's blank
right now
i should be able to go up and try some
type of material and i'll figure it out
on stage right which is honestly i feel
like half of the game of standup is that
here's the problem though
and i don't know even though what i was
saying because when i was up there i'm
like cool i'm just gonna look at the
crowd and do some crowd work couldn't
see anybody cause the lights were so
bright they're so bright i was like wow
no crowd work
so i had a moment where i freaked out a
little bit on the inside but i just said
[ __ ] it let's just go jokes after jokes
after jokes don't even give yourself
breathing time yeah like just just
[ __ ] deer running through them but
you were getting laughs yeah that's the
thing is you were just like
but like they were they were laughing
like you got he got a few like really
good pops and it wasn't it wasn't a room
where they like like i said they weren't
giving it away yeah it was kind of a
rough room dude because like the other
part that kind of made me nervous was
there was when we got there there was
like two or three comics that i wanted
before they did not get much laughs they
bombed and i don't know they didn't bomb
but it was just it was it was it was
like yeah and it was just there's
certain rooms where the energy is really
good and you can like build momentum
well not just that but there's like so
it's like certain clubs or certain rooms
you build momentum like you get them to
laugh and it rolls into the next lap and
the next it's like almost like you know
in street fighter when you hit a dude
it's like times two times three times
four yeah the multiplier yeah you could
do that but this room was like even if
you got them to laugh it would die quick
yes and then you it was like always like
starting over like it was it was like
they're like
and then you it's like you're starting
fresh every time
and
also like some of the jokes that were
it's like you i've gotten big pastas
before they were like getting little
pops or like medium pops and i was like
okay like that you had to like really
drag them like grab them like gaining
the trust of the audience was hard that
night so like
i can't remember too much but i remember
i heard i don't remember big laughs i
just remember like some giggles but
usually like if that happens you'll be
able to loosen them up and they'll be
more perceptive to the jokes that come
after but just like you said it felt
like it was
something like start go start go start
go so in my mind i was like i [ __ ]
bombed yeah i got off stage i felt
terrible at first you didn't bomb you
definitely didn't bum i saw this guy the
next day because we trained afterwards
and i'm like so how'd it go man and he
goes i don't remember a day
it was a fever dream i was like so you
don't know if you did good or not no i
didn't record anything so i don't know
what what happened what i said i just
remember a couple of jokes and i just
started working it the night before and
i fell asleep crying
because my question is when you got up
on stage
what is the inner voice that you're is
like talking to you first thing that i
did when i got on stage was [ __ ] jason
chen yeah jason cheney [ __ ] jason
this [ __ ] you were mad
and then afterwards it was just like
let's do some crowd work can't see
anybody what is happening
panicked yeah and then i just started
that's the thing i don't remember so i
just started going into this bag of
whatever jokes that i had
and i don't even know like some of those
i'm pretty sure some others i don't even
write down and i wish i would have
figured out what i said i remember a
couple of things you were talking you
talked about your dad definitely about
the ghost joke was funny when we talk
about what he hits you and then he's
like dude
or whatever that's funny
uh
immigrant child uh you talked about um
the slapping story you finished with
that one that was good too yeah people
really got a good laugh that was the
only thing i knew that got a good laugh
but
it was the thing that i didn't expect
would get a good laugh i guess that's a
pretty good story because you're not
really great you just don't know what
the how to present it and stand up
though yeah right because yeah podcast
is a lot more casual versus like when
you do it on stage as a way to kind of
set it up to get the big laugh
so like one of the things that i was
thinking in my head and as as i was
processing it was like
i don't remember the exact jokes but
there were times where i'm like the
setup is off like this could have been a
bigger laugh setup is off this could
have been a bigger laugh you like didn't
build it enough is that what you mean
yeah there's like
i'm not sure if you relate to this but
this like
when you when you say these jokes it
goes cool cool cool and you're supposed
to build up to this this momentous
moment and i felt a lot of my jokes were
doing this semi laugh but the pop was
off because i didn't set it up right but
i don't know what the joke is so i don't
even know how to rewrite it now
but that's what it felt like on stage so
i felt like [ __ ] when i got off i'm like
damn this was [ __ ] terrible and then
pat reminded me like well the guy before
you bombed and i'm like oh that's right
so he killed the room dude
well that part didn't help either well i
mean the guy yeah guy before him did
bomb legitimately but but the thing is
is you didn't bomb like you were getting
even like even the the like mediocre
laughs or whatever like that's still
something like that bombing is where
there's just no laughter
no nothing previously
that happened right before you uh but
that that mean the head that didn't
happen to you so you're already in your
head about that yeah but the thing is is
that like i said that didn't happen to
you you did get and you even got some
cause it was like it was like the cr it
was like a smaller crowd right at the
front in front of the stage there was
like a gap where there wasn't anybody
sitting and there was a bar it was hard
for the laughs to like for some reason
to reach the back i don't just either
way the acoustics i don't know what it
was but there was a couple moments where
i heard like a good laugh all the way to
the back and i was like oh that's good
that's a that's a good pop oh yeah
christ so that happened at least two or
three times yeah in like a seven minute
set or seven to ten still not bad for
not doing stan not being prepared at all
yeah it's pretty good and anxious right
before shooting you're jumping over
your pants when they're going on stage
that's crazy bro it was hilarious dude
it's wonderful experience was so funny
because as soon as i put as soon as i
saw the picture of david on the marquee
i already knew what jason did and i was
like damn that's [ __ ] hilarious that
he did that dude he literally just was
like yeah come check out the show and
was like hey can you get a spot and just
put him just [ __ ] just put him in
that position with the pressure where it
would have yeah it was like almost
impossible for you to
say no it is exactly like because it
ain't no [ __ ] right well the thing
about it is too it's like
i can't consistently say on this podcast
that yeah i enjoy stand up i've done
stand-up and then when this happens i
just go no and i cry and i go home
i can't live with myself no and even if
nobody knew about it i know about that
like i know that when i went home
exactly you should have been able to do
something even if you bombed you should
have been able to do something yeah and
just the problem was that the anxiety
was erasing all the jokes in my head it
just kept like if you see like
if you ever written a note on on your uh
iphone right and you swear to god you
wrote something and you go back to it as
a blank page that's what it felt like
yeah so i couldn't figure out what the
[ __ ] is going i was like why
hey man you bout to go up shut the [ __ ]
up and don't i will kill you that's what
i was thinking like let me think about
my jokes and then patching me to the bar
we got a beer and that helped me calm
down yeah the beer helps it [ __ ]
caught my nerves down and i got to a
point where i was like [ __ ] it i don't
even care anymore yeah exactly yeah and
you need and that's that's a good way to
go up there like i don't even care like
you should be you should feel something
but like that sense of like [ __ ] it
whatever happens happens like you need
that yeah it was cool because like uh
the club his name is john i believe yeah
and he was like hey
you don't have to go up right he goes i
understand
he pranked you
it goes next week if you want to come
back just do it then yeah we'll give you
like two three minutes so the big
question is are you gonna go back next
week oh next year for sure i just need
to get this store done like oh they said
next week no next year next year yeah
next week probably not but there's no
part of you that was like oh i missed
this [ __ ] you know the the thing that i
really enjoyed was doing it with pat and
jason yeah right it was just with the
squad it was just that in general was a
really the thing about it is i kind of
sometimes like when [ __ ] up things
happen because it's just funny yeah
these are great stories like this is
something you'll remember forever almost
it's just [ __ ] hilarious and at the
same time i was pissed but i couldn't
stop laughing yeah because it's like
this is some sitcom [ __ ] dude
like what kind of sitcom [ __ ]
scenario is this thing dude yeah and
jason just thought like first of all
i've known jason maybe i don't know five
six months we've seen each other three
times the audacity yeah like the [ __ ]
audacity that he thought i wasn't going
to kill him yeah yeah right but he knows
i love him like so it's like mother i
want to sock you but i wouldn't feel
good if i did and it's hard to like be
mad at that full problem it's so hard
especially because of the pep talk that
he was giving me yeah and then he kind
of like compartmentalized what was
happening he goes i go up and i just
read it off my phone he goes this is a
place for you to work yeah just do
that's cool it's a gym yeah that's a gym
yeah it was super low stakes but it was
a good it's a fun room i like that
really i like that spot a lot and it was
a burlesque place too i i was i was like
titties wow yeah this is fantastic so
they had like three bullets they had a
uh i think it was like three comedians
then they would have like dancers and
then three comedians dancers
so it's kind of like hard to follow
after some chick shows or tits you know
well what what
i mean you can do it don't get me wrong
you could do it but it's the the it's a
higher level of difficulty what it does
is it just messes up the momentum
because like comedy is like
the reason why it's like when you when
you have like a host and then the
feature in the headliner it's like all
building up like
you're getting people in the mood
they're like there to laugh yeah what
happens with this is like you do comedy
comedy comedy they're like they're
warming up warming up and then dancing
and they're like okay and then it's
reset it's like all the reset in that
room it's like a reset
there's no multipliers
he's like he goes
you don't want to go up and watch the
ladies i was like what do you mean i
walked up i was like this is very nice
i understood what you guys meant when it
was like it's a little more difficult
here yeah it is but it's not
bad though it's not bad you know what i
mean like it's not difficult in a bad
way it's more like it is true it feels
like a very safe space for you to just
try new things out in a way that's the
perfect place to try new material
because if you can pull it off there
then you know like in a club or whatever
it'll you'll do well i mean but that's
that's what's great about like [ __ ] up
even bar shows or like doing bad or even
open mics like that's why i still like
doing open mics because they're rough
and like if you can get reactions there
if you can especially a big one you're
like oh man this is going to smash in
like a real room it was pretty
interesting right and i think like it
kind of puts in perspective of like
after everything settled down in the
next like first of all i had a crazy
adrenaline dump so the next day
exhausted i was trying to work out with
this fool i had zero [ __ ] energy so
tired dude how did you feel that night
though huh
it felt good afterwards right he said
he's gonna [ __ ] sleep this guy i
couldn't sleep i bet i fell asleep at
5am you were damn for real while you
were just amped you were just like i
don't know why bro
come here
[Laughter]
i want to have sex
chasing her my feelings tonight i just
kind of sat there and i just thought
about a few things and then i
i was like about a few things i was like
what happened like what just [ __ ]
happened
and i the funny thing is is like old
habits die really hard so you know when
i was younger
every time i did stand up i went home
and i reworked jokes
went home and i reword joe so whatever i
remembered i just started reworking the
joke that's the best time to do it too
when it's fresh for your [ __ ] head
well and also that and just because you
get like this like f if you have a good
set you you're like creative you're like
you're you you just you're just on that
wavelength and that's the that's the
best time to write jokes because you're
already you're feeling funny you're
feeling confident and you'll you'll just
you'll try anything you're like [ __ ] a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like it's the
best time to write is right after a show
and i have like this weird and i always
talk about this like
extremely like competitive side that i
have not with you guys but there was a
guy that was outside really [ __ ] nice
guy right like i like his [ __ ] guts
no no no no
you start creating scenarios in your
head right that don't [ __ ] exist yeah
none of this was said none of this
happened there was no body language that
allowed me to think this way but the guy
comes up and he's like trying to be nice
right he's like hey dude just go work
he's like it doesn't matter just go up
there and i'm thinking in my mind i
don't know this guy i'm like who the
[ __ ] are you
but he's super [ __ ] nice yeah it was
really nice yeah i was like god this
guy's really sweet but in my mind i'm
like you don't talk to me like this
you give me a pep talk i don't know you
yeah you know man have fun [ __ ] you dude
and i really actually really liked that
guy he was super [ __ ] chill he was
really nice you know too yeah and then
he goes up and then you know he doesn't
do that hot and then my mom likes
give me advice [ __ ]
you know who do you think you are but
it's interesting though like all those
things that i felt when i was like
i was telling pat like that day i felt
like a 17 year old all over again the
first time i ever did stand up i was
tired and it felt just like that and i
was scared i was actually sweating my
ass off dude i would imagine i bet those
lights are hot too yeah i just seen
titties and then all of a sudden i'm on
stage i just had a beer i was sweating
my ass off but there was something that
i noticed too he knows that was
glistening yeah he wasn't honestly
that's another thing too is in the like
as soon as we parked the car when we're
walking i look and he's just glistening
he looks like a glazed donut like you
just like i don't know where it wasn't
even that hot and i was like there
you're all right butterball turkey dude
that's hilarious pork belly lechon dude
that's what i [ __ ] look like dude
baby let's get it yeah he was glazed
dude yeah i was like
this guy was just laughing at me
it was it was funny dude
also i've been there i know exactly what
you're going through and it's just from
the outside it's so funny to see your
friend go through that like chris sosa
too just he was on the podcast before
and he was telling me you know hey do
you ever feel that before you go up on
stage you know that people are going to
be like oh david soh who has you know x
amount of followers who's been doing
comedy online it's actually not that
funny and i was like i do now thanks
thank you for planning that [ __ ]
scene in my head you know and i started
thinking about that [ __ ] is like am i
full of [ __ ] am i somebody who did stand
up when he was younger and he actually
was never good and i thought i was
actually somewhat decent you know and i
start going through this like imposter
syndrome a lot yeah that and it started
hitting me really really hard like yeah
can i live up to this stuff that all the
[ __ ] that i said even if there is no
material because i know the best comics
on earth you you blindside them with
[ __ ] they can do absolutely anything and
that's what i was thinking about like
well if i can't do at least some of this
maybe i'm not that good of a comic you
know and then you start [ __ ] it
starts to eat away at you and that's
yeah but you're also four years out the
game probably like when's the last time
you've been on stage you know like doing
stand-up stamp it might even be longer
than four years i might even be
shortening it's been a long time like
i'm talking about doing stand-up in
front of a crowd that doesn't know who i
am yeah
that is a scary scary place to be
because sometimes because when you
because the hardest part like we were
talking about is gaining the crowd's
trust when people come to see you you
already have their trust so they're also
a little more willing to hear you out
yeah this was scary i was like these
people don't know who i am they don't
give a [ __ ] about me and i have to prove
my worth yeah exactly but that's what
makes you strong as a comedian yeah like
that's what makes you so that's
confidence right knowing that you could
do that [ __ ] on the fly like that and
then going to a club that you have stuff
prepared already you're probably
knocking out the park and then jason
cheney just ambushes me dude yeah and
then you're going to drop your special
which is probably going to be called
chinito poppy of course
i told him
i wasn't going to say this on the
podcast say it
one of the biggest motivating factors
was i'm sitting in the room and i go
brendan does this
[Music]
i can't do this that's all i want you to
say i can't do this i can do this this
guy has people who hate him yeah and he
doesn't he still goes up every [ __ ]
night yeah he goes up there what the
[ __ ] am i yeah you just gotta go up
there dude
like jason cheney roasted my ass too on
this like text thread that we had too
i was like dude in this group like me me
uh pat and jason i was like i'm the
bread in the shop of this group i was
like no you're not because at least he
goes up in the stand
and that [ __ ] hurt me a lot
he
ruthless bro that [ __ ] was ruthless as
[ __ ] and i sat there taking a [ __ ] and i
cried yeah yeah [ __ ] jason cheney
that'll hurt he want me you wouldn't
expect him to cut so deep huh yeah deep
sometimes yeah
does he give you [ __ ] like that we talk
[ __ ] to each other all the time yeah
yeah all the time i literally have him
in my phone it's hard
yeah yeah it's hard
we had a text that i forgot because i
just added them on my phone yeah and it
was pat and said tart i'm like who's
[ __ ] oh that's jason it's just
of course of course dude it was so fun
stand up is the [ __ ] bro stand up is
[ __ ] amazing we were talking about it
too like um i was just thinking about
the other day of like
why is it that i had this like weird
feeling towards
um actors and celebrities right like why
is it that when they become well known
the worst qualities about them start to
shine the most where they like to punch
down on their peers in terms of like oh
you're not doing this i'm better than
you yeah why do what does every [ __ ]
um actor become an activist and the
biggest reason why is because i've been
in both circles now is that comics check
other comics
right i was checking famous people
actors don't do that you know what
actors do they'll hate their project
then they go dude you were amazing the
way that you emoted in that scene i
appreciate you do keep doing what you're
doing and that's the biggest [ __ ]
difference comics will be like
hey man that's set you know yeah
they won't look at your film and be like
hey bro that [ __ ] i wasn't my favorite
you know but hey i'm glad you tried yeah
right because there's a way to sandwich
like critique and compliments comics
will do that all the time with these
actors i have a huge issue with them
because they're always on their high
horse right and they always like to
pretend like they're these perfect human
beings and you should follow me because
i'm a good person and i'm a great
representation for my community and i
hate that because it's false because i
know these people i'm like you're the
biggest piece of [ __ ] i've ever met in
my [ __ ] life is there anybody you can
think of like off the top of your head
dude i don't don't yeah let's not now
dude we're just three friends just
chatting it up that's going on just
happened to have some mics in front of
us yeah listen when i become a
millionaire it's all coming out yes dude
the damn it so but as of right now
i'm trying to be peace pearl he's pissed
every day i wake up and it's like a
piece
you wake up and choose violence bro i do
not today was rough though we went
six rounds damn this [ __ ] was
driven like he was going to fight jake
paul thing
yeah
i need another round and he was like
brother he was like talking [ __ ] someone
threw something and he went
he did it he shook his head and was like
oh
you know like when you start like you
match the energy of the other person
yeah right and you know brian i don't
know why you're talking [ __ ] bro give me
[ __ ] earlier hold on a second you shut
your filthy [ __ ] mouth
you [ __ ] ching chong bing bong let me
just do this right
one of my favorite things when this guy
calls me a ching chung
because i look way more asian than him
i think i'm starting to look more brown
than anything i'm starting to look more
salty more ambiguous bro you look like
you when in the future when they project
like in 100 or years from now what
people will look like you already look
like that guy when everyone's just like
already made it yeah you look like that
guy so we're a perfect human being
that's terrible if i'm the perfect man
we were at jk and i was showing the guys
everybody was talking about how like how
how white my eyes are and they were like
like clowning on me and off camera i
showed them the picture that little gray
uh
the gray man i have to show this to you
and if you could edit it in the
picture that'd be solid thanks for
adding more work but then yeah but you
know add a dragon over here okay
yeah whatever whoa i [ __ ] my time but
all right go ahead yeah dude what else
you gotta do okay
what does he gotta do but and then you
look at the side by side comparison and
then now with my head shape i'm like bro
i look just like dude years ago i saw
this it's a it's a meme of like this
it's like a it's like a cracker
yeah it's like a cpr dummy or something
and it it's this little gray guy and
they always do like the meme was like
when you're at your boy's house and his
mom starts beating [ __ ] out of your
friend yeah and he's sitting there and
he's like he's kind of looking like this
like
and i remember seeing that i sent it to
nick i was like you look i've literally
seen you make this exact face and bro
it's you you're the great guy i'm the
great guy dude and you showed him and
they were like
that's absolutely 100 true that's you
and i was like [ __ ] patrick dude
you're the grey man five years in the
making you're the future this is my
favorite thing about you is watching you
flip from your personality of happy go
lucky let's let's [ __ ] do touch butt
in the parking lot guy to oh you hit me
you know it's a weird it's such a weird
thing it's like you get possessed
it's gotta come out somewhere no you're
a nice person but your competitive side
still exists and it's a very odd thing
for me to see like i just don't expect
it i'm like oh cool cool
you guys were sparring i was like damn
you guys are going 10 minutes i said
we're doing light work i'm like what are
you yelling at me
yeah because you guys
[ __ ] bro i was just like hey it's 10
minutes and you went we're doing like
work right pat yeah his voice gets all
deep you know what it's [ __ ] up what's
that timer one minute who cares we don't
do timers
like whoa this giant voice issue yeah
you're right no time sometimes i do that
or like i'll i'll like get really worked
up i like it but in my head it's okay
but in my head it's like it's fun and
funny like it's it's fun i like it
remember what he said after he was like
sometimes i just like getting in the hit
in the face like
and he like you weren't joking you
mongolian warrior dude
no that's good it's because it's in you
yeah you like you have that spirit it's
good i know yeah i don't mind i think
it's good i just don't like being a
little [ __ ] dude it's gonna come out
somewhere that competitive thing feels
good though dude it is like makes you
feel alive i feel it too like when you
kick me too i was like [ __ ] up
and you did like when i started getting
tired too i was like [ __ ] this fool like
i started i literally i'm like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] yeah i'm trying to crack
and that's what keeps you going though
yeah that's what keeps you going because
you don't want to stop and i like that i
like the ebbs and flows of that i like
you know i like it too do you feel like
you're dead tired and you want to
[ __ ] leave it it feels good it was
funny i got hit in the eye today and
then
uh it wasn't a hard hit but it just hit
directly in the eye
so i saw double for the first time and i
was like oh we gotta stop because i
don't know what i'm looking at yeah like
it he's like brian split in two and then
i just thought slowly was back in the
one that's why we gotta stop sparm and
then i was like i stopped and the funny
thing is just that i was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you know someone went
back and we did two more rounds you know
what i mean he did flip because at first
he was like worried for a sec i could
see in his eyes and then
flipped yeah he was like i'll go [ __ ]
and i was like jesus christ man jesus
christ
it's really fun when it gets to that
point especially because brian too when
you when you connected brian brian talks
[ __ ] yeah brian talks [ __ ] i didn't
realize that he talks [ __ ] like that
yeah he talks [ __ ] really like
brian talk some [ __ ] like so
i'm trying to talk some [ __ ] yeah called
giggs the hotline because we were doing
whatever what i i did a slack i did a
slap hook to a cross right and he was
like what are you doing with that i
didn't do nothing i'm like
and then he threw a crossback at me i
was like no
just going back and forth that's funny
and it was fun yeah it was fantastic i
didn't like it but i was sitting on the
side all cold not training at all and i
was like you guys are going too hard
it wasn't bad at all like honestly like
i just the only thing i keep in my mind
is what he told me was like you can go a
little hard on the leg kicks a little
hard on the body but keep it soft to the
head yeah and so i was like okay we can
go a little hard on the leg kicks so
then he was like i'm going to go 150 it
was not 150 percent
he threw some [ __ ] haymakers at brian
to the point where i felt the wind like
my hair gusted a little bit oh wow but
we we already amped up our
[ __ ] at that point
you guys have trained a lot too so
you're yeah
that's like the truth he hits me hard
but i feel like i'm such a fat noggin it
doesn't really do much like yeah in
terms of like fat noggin yeah i got this
[ __ ] dome on me yeah i don't think
your head's that big
you think you got a big-ass head wait
till i lose his weight and you'll see i
look like a [ __ ] alien dude it sucks
people look at my face and like what
happened to your body
like where did it go like my brain just
absorbed all the nutrients and then my
[ __ ] dome is used because you're
making mine heads it's disgusting like
this tiny [ __ ] anglo-saxon face dude
coveted of all korean people you know
what a korean compliment is what your
faces are so small
really yeah they go
people love petite things right they're
just like tiny things yeah just little
things your face it's a tiny
and that's like the biggest costume you
can get they go oh no my face is not too
small yeah yeah
i have no idea oh brother you got a good
head bro you're gonna get that you got a
good head dog damn i mean you gotta get
a good head
you get good bro
odd numbers i'm not like you guys do
your class man do you think i'm running
class you guys do your thing sarah says
she wants to train tell her to pull up
dude let me tell you something that
[ __ ] is big she'll [ __ ] knock
somebody out
i saw her back and [ __ ] i'm like this
girl could carry the [ __ ] weight of
the world
she'll be talking to me and then she'll
like shove me on accident i'll be like
oh [ __ ] she's crazy bro yeah
let me tell you this funny ass [ __ ]
story millie's right and i sit down and
the first thing she says
this girl is [ __ ] hilarious by the
way dude funny met her once love this
girl she goes are you what pat said to
me pat says that if i [ __ ] broke into
the house he didn't expect me coming in
i can't choke him out
what
conversation
we just sat down nice to meet you
my name's david
and he demonstrates he goes show him the
choke hold that you're going to put the
joker just like this i'm like yeah it's
not going to happen she literally went
like this she tried to do it to
demonstrate that i was on the way to the
bathroom and she went she snuck up on me
like this and she with two arms like
this and she went
like that and like it i just i just
rolled out and she was like i would have
if she was like i almost got you and i
was like no you didn't dude i'll [ __ ]
your ass up today even at the gym
at the gym she was like i'm gonna knock
you out she's like i'm gonna start
training i'm gonna knock you out and i
was like no you're not and she's like
you don't think i can you don't [ __ ]
think i can and i was like you can't
i was like she's like i'm come true i
have my hand behind my back and i will
hospitalize i know what it is though i
kind of saw a glimpse of that the way
he's like smiling and he's like he's all
cool and [ __ ] he goes you can't i'd be
mad too bro i'll be like what the [ __ ]
yeah i can't knock you off dude she gets
crazy sometimes sometimes we have to
scuffle you know what i mean who wears
the exchanges most of the time me dude
come on now of course come on i love
this video pat beats up his girlfriend
and i'll throw my name you throw my name
in the hat she swings she'd be trying to
like she'll try to tickle me she'll try
to put her fingers in my butt fingers in
the butt is usually the cause of what
causes exactly yeah and then she'll like
you know how you're a lady sometimes
she'll get all like giggly and like i
just want to mess with you and see you
react
she'll do that to me and then obviously
your boy gonna start doing arm drags you
would start doing barrambolos and [ __ ]
yeah yeah and she's like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa you can't be doing this jiu
jitsu [ __ ] you started it yeah and i'll
be like that's why you gotta train dude
most the time me and her scuffle is
because she's literally trying to lick
my ass or put her finger in my ass you
don't like that you don't like tongues
on your butt i don't i'm not trying to
like have that happen but there's no
[ __ ] allowed here and then also it's
just it's just
well look i have had it happen yeah and
it is okay but the thing is
on a scale from one to ten
where would you rank it let's see it's
like
she's in she isn't afraid that when she
licks you're gonna drop a [ __ ] tamar
she's crazy she literally has tried to
get in there and i'd be like yo like i
let me shower at least yeah
are you nuts so it took a while for her
to like for me to allow access and so
she's only done it one time
okay
once or twice it's never it hasn't been
more than two times but
uh she she tried for years and then i
would be like no dude i don't want that
to happen and then she literally looked
at me and was like i want to do it
because you don't want me to do it yeah
see that was my question that is rape
that is like that is though that is the
big like you're a rapist that's a power
trip you like it because i don't want it
she's like yeah you know that's why i
want to do it that's harvey weinstein
bro you're a [ __ ] even with harvey
weinstein for reals and then like she'll
like set up traps like she'll put like
[ __ ] springs booty traps yeah booty
traps like she'll throw marbles on
ground i stumble and she's like
trying
alone
so [ __ ] cracks off we start scuffling
yeah
someone's trying to lick your ass
against your will there's going to be a
scuffle dude you live in a prison bro
yeah for real yeah i'm sorry i didn't
know your like at-home life was like
that yeah i'm sorry it's bad yeah i'm
sorry she's not a tiny lady too very
pretty very buff though yeah
i was like hey don't hold her wrist too
hard girl
she's ready to roll dude she's crazy
before we continue my lovely genius
brain farts this podcast is brought to
you by better help you guys know i love
better help and i'm going to keep on
talking about this lovely sponsor
because it's helped me so much and it
can help you too for those of you out
there that do not focus on your mental
health because you think it makes you
look weak or you're just shy there's
nothing to worry about better help is
there for you how well would you take
care of your car if you had to keep the
same one your entire life well that's
how our brains work so why don't you
treat it the same way there are plenty
of ways to support a healthy brain like
learning a new language or taking power
naps there's also better help and online
therapy i've been using betterhelp for
quite a while and it helps me sorts out
my thoughts because you know being on
social media can be freaking
rough mentally emotionally and
everything else and having my therapist
help me and walk me through my problems
and sessions have been really really
great better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you don't
want to you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
genius that's better h-e-l-p-com
genius she's wiry too she's got like
that wiry yeah she's ready to go
crackhead energy yeah let me ask you
this
if you guys were out in public she's the
type of girl to be like oh you've tried
to [ __ ] with me huh do you know my man
oh no i don't think she would do that
she's not she's not stupid i feel like
she's going to [ __ ] up somebody in the
[ __ ] head before she
she would but she's not she don't she's
not like
i don't think she's not dumb like that
um
can we tell the story about the personal
trainer
yeah so we we all go to this gym
right
this is when i was surprised as sarah
because there's a personal trainer there
very nice guy
but he likes to be very persistent with
some of his leads that he gets so he
goes around the gym and he's like hey
give me his descriptor right now so i
know who he is
uh what is his description bald nah he
nah he is the guy that matches his
[ __ ] jordan shoes with everything no
not that guy that guy's actually that
ridiculous he's actually kind of nice
he's a sweetheart he's a sweetheart
do i is his style my style not my style
no i thought he posted hilarious videos
he does yes yeah ironically he'll learn
not trying to be funny but it's funny
yeah but the other person trainer he was
very persistent with with trying to book
sarah uh
a free session right and she was like
oh no i don't i don't think i want to do
it no thank you i can't she kept like
making up excuses
any time he would walk in the room she
would be like oh god it's so awkward i
don't want to talk to him and he would
go up and asking her to be like what the
[ __ ]
shut up shut up the whole dance behind
the [ __ ] chair
for everyone to see what are you crazy
shut your mouth so she'll
he'll keep going up to her and be like
hey like let's do that session and she's
like
oh no it's okay why don't you just flex
in front of them like do you see these
and i'm like i'm like sarah bro please
just tell him you don't want to train
with him so he'll [ __ ] leave you
alone and you'll go on his day but the
fact that she was so like oh i don't
want to i don't want to yeah it was kind
of surprising to me because i feel like
sarah's kind of like should talk some
[ __ ] or am i completely wrong i feel
like you know if it came down to it she
would but like she's not actually like
really nice she's like
she wouldn't be like that but yeah that
guy was he's just
he's trying to [ __ ] yeah for sure he's
trying to [ __ ] so hard bro and he's
busting it down i see him bro i see him
work i'm like this guy he's good at what
he does man yeah he's good at liking him
i've seen him hinging at yeah
like swiping he's never approached me
for personal training yeah because you
don't got that good [ __ ] bro have you
seen this donk though bro yeah that's
just great a
yeah he's talking to me and nick about
what one day he was like oh nick's just
a great guy he's just a [ __ ] great
guy that's what's awesome because i
literally talked to nick and nick's like
i hate that guy
no he's actually really nice bro shut up
no
no
first time i met him i was like bro stop
asking me all these questions doug like
i'm just trying to get my workout in but
you know he wore me down over time and i
went on a date with him dude that's
great dude how's the hand job nice
he caught he calls this guy a [ __ ]
sweetheart he gives this guy [ __ ]
love eyes at the gym he's like hey
what's up man how are you yeah because
that's funny
i didn't know when i first came to la
because i didn't have any white friends
right i just never grew around a lot of
white people uh
like white people like to call you buddy
yeah and i think that's disrespectful
everybody so i didn't know but yeah i
didn't know that that's like an okay
thing because that sounds like you're
talking down to me or boss i'm like
don't call
no bossa nova the restaurant it's like a
there's a really popular spot out in
hollywood that's where everybody like
all the music producers go because it's
open 24 7.
we spend time over there
do you think we go to these places yeah
you talk about some trendy [ __ ] anything
you [ __ ] homeless [ __ ] all right i'm
practically homeless
but bossa nova it's not expensive it's
just a place that has big portions and
it's just open 24 7. okay so when i
first came to la i'm like i'm very
uncultured at this point i don't know
what charcuterie is i don't know nothing
right
let me get some salami
reactions yeah sure lunchables out dog
shout out to connery so i'm over here
just you know baggy pants whatever doing
my [ __ ] and then all of a sudden this
guy's like hey what do you want buddy
and i'm like look this guy was like what
the [ __ ] did you say yeah what the [ __ ]
excuse me i was like you [ __ ] just
call me buddy your [ __ ] buddy
and this dude is quick on the trigger
bro yeah dude
when i was here buddy i'm in a new city
i'm in a city i don't know where i'm at
and you immediately just go to your
defenses because i thought this guy was
talking [ __ ] to me i'm like i ain't your
[ __ ] buddy bro and then i stopped and
then my buddy was looking he's like what
did he say to you i was like he called
me buddy i was like that's not offensive
i'm like it's not because bro people
call people buddy all the time yeah but
it's the way you say it yeah you know
what i mean do you think he had like a
it's the tone like hey what's up like if
someone's like oh what's up buddy how
you doing like high pitched that's cool
it's either that or this it's either hey
what's up buddy or what's up
buddy yeah
i had to apologize though i [ __ ]
apologize like a [ __ ] i was like
did you hey bro uh i'm poor
i was like and poor people don't like
the word buddy i apologize
it's okay man i was like by the way i'm
gonna leave you a fat tip i'm i felt so
[ __ ] bad for sure yeah yeah but then
i started hearing it more and more often
people are like oh they just say it it's
just buddy it's just it's just the work
i've called like friends of mine buddies
like i've been like like talking about
my friends like oh yeah my buddies but i
don't think i've ever called anybody
like what's up buddy yeah yeah that it
made me feel like this is true
like i'll talk about my friends about oh
those are my buddies like like that yeah
but so she was talking down to me yeah
he was what's up buddy you know what a
nice alternative is you throw out a
little player what's up player like you
know what i mean that's always
[ __ ] yeah yeah but they go
what's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
fire that's sick fire what's up spectrum
boy
spectra boy [ __ ] boy dick [ __ ] future
[ __ ] boy
uh to buy a car
a car dealer dude yeah they said buddy
to me too and i'm like yeah but they're
all scumbags bro you know why guy is a
weird one too yeah hi guy hey what's up
guy it sounds like i don't know if
someone says he's just [ __ ] guy
hey what's up guy what's up guys what's
up you little pano
that's nice so [ __ ] boys
are right yeah because
i don't know where buddy like where what
what in nature where is that word like
what is that yeah yeah if we look up in
the dictionary buddy does buddy show up
what is that yeah where is that is that
i'm really rethinking if he was really
talking down to me now he probably was
buddy what's up buddy i should have
[ __ ] say but you should have beat his
[ __ ] eyes and you should retake that
tip back i feel like bud is less
insulting than buddy like what's up bud
bud butt is what i talk to that's how i
talk to kids this is what it is exactly
it's not like he was talking to me like
i was a child that's oh you know what
like buddy is good for kids when you
have kids yeah it's a buddy oh yeah
kid's buddy all day what's up a little
[ __ ] boy and you shook his head
crying again [ __ ] [ __ ]
nick talks when he sparks too yeah he
does hey you like that cross [ __ ] boy
well i don't talk about [ __ ] bro [ __ ]
you let your hands do the talking unless
you stalling then i'll give you some
[ __ ] stalling
what are you doing stand up dude yeah
says i did it it's time for you to do it
i'm not a stand-up comedian either
i'm a podcaster you've been doing this
since you were 16. yeah you used to
honestly i'm telling you you could do it
you could do it yeah dude
well you know what i don't know man you
could do it i don't know we got
somewhere yeah yeah you could do it hey
next week we'll set you up in the room
god damn right next week
i will be in the crowd laughing my ass
even if you're not funny
even if you're not funny i'm gonna get
everybody i'm gonna do this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i don't think i have anything to
talk about bro
you know what i mean what you got a lot
to talk about you sound just like me
yesterday the other day but you are a
comedian you have you have i am not i i
i really wish that time i should do i
should retell that eric andre story
that's all in here
the one that bombed really hard i should
tell that story on stage have you guys
seen this show that eric andre did it's
a prank show and i just go on this whole
[ __ ] tangent i would love to know how
to just try stand up once so you can
understand what i went through no i hey
i'm a very empathetic person bro i you
know i believe all women i feel like
what you said up there on that stage i
well your experience i believe i
internalize and i i feel like i went up
on stage that's how i feel you sound
like a sexual assault victim bro yeah
and that's what i do you know that's my
thing that's my mo yes your ammo yeah i
believe all women you believe in women
nick believes all women i do
amber hurt is innocent you know what
yeah i think out of all of them she
probably is the least innocent for sure
she used to be really really attractive
i think the trial took years off her
face like if you look at the beginning
of the trial to the end she just looks
older and haggard continually and there
was a i saw i went back to the clips why
did they dress her like [ __ ] mrs
doubtfire i think she did that she
dressed really weird i heard she was
copying his wardrobe somehow i don't
even know what that means but
well how did you wait why did she do
that she just looks like that's what i'm
saying i don't know i don't know that's
what i heard someone honestly i just
heard that she dressed like captain jack
sparrow but like a nice cleaned up
version she should if she would have
came in like captain jack sparrow
actually she would have won some points
i think that would have got her she was
drunk on the stand though yeah i think
he comes in and she's like hey pat i
want to give you a blowy you say yes or
no
look at this guy she'll probably suck
the penis off your body bro i would be
like i don't think you would probably
say yeah
yeah because of this scumbag what do you
mean i don't think she's like i'm just
stuck with this she just comes up she's
like how sexy i'm saying polite if you
turn it even though she is like the
whole background she's like you would be
like let's get it
yeah
i may play with fire bro
i mean i mean the thing is i have no
toms for that [ __ ] man
well it's not like you're starting a
relationship with her bro
in my head bro i'm getting his ass
i'm saying like i'm not saying i would
go pursue it but if she came up to you
and was like look this is a one-off
spin-offs [ __ ] series
one episode i'ma blow ya yeah you want
that yeah hey you're setting up weird
scenarios i'm not saying that's any of
that i'm thinking she's gonna suck your
dick and then she's gonna probably
follow you a little bit ask you where
you're at follow you no none of that
she's going to eat your ass and be like
where's the chef yeah this is so
delicious
compliments to the [ __ ] what a puff of
[ __ ]
i must meet the chef yeah
[ __ ] charcoal report is fired
yeah no none of the followings
if it's just in a vacuum like
you will be get your dick sucked by her
why would i bro you gotta think about
the butterfly effect no no butterflies
gotta think about the butterfly if
there's a butterfly effect evolved now
she's crazy
that's not that it's just not as fun
just a nice little bee just say yeah
dude nice little bee
under the boardwalk dude if if she
sucked elon musk's dick bro that means
she did your name is up on this like
this resume that's a legendary resume
did you see that [ __ ] yeah yeah it looks
like a bag of flour yeah but it's also
like dude he probably has no time to do
anything yeah i'm not really like
judging him i was just i'm like but
you're surprised i've seen like dead
bodies before
but but also what i'll say about elon
musk it's like you don't have to be in
really good shape but also just get some
sun just just you know throw on a little
sunscreen and just get some rays what i
don't understand is like houses chest
cavity so big yeah that's what i'm
saying the shade heavies bro because
it's not like he has something because
you would think like a gut like okay
like out of shape guy gut makes sense
but like it's like his chest cavity he
looks like a minecraft character yeah
he's like really boxers and then like
nancy pelosi or elon musk let me tell
you some nancy pelosi i could bury my
face in that [ __ ]
all day big ass titties motorboat that's
a cruise ship baby
yeah that shocked me dude i don't care
about her political views i don't care
about her [ __ ] uh [ __ ] stock
trading [ __ ] yeah just let me die in
those [ __ ] fun bags let me just rest
my head on them a little bit she's
hiding those insider stock tradings in
those titties boys
national
[Laughter]
[Music]
she got the heaviest dogs
uh you could catch nick at nick the ear
if you're looking for personal training
trying to get your life back together
fitness he is a
fitness coach a mentor and he will guide
you to fitness every day this man has
got me doing lunges i can do lunges
again yeah dude david david's been
working hard and he's a [ __ ] animal
it is it is fantastic you can find
patrick.t.riley on the instagram look
out for his shows he will be doing stand
up it's coming back nobody cares about
kovid this guy out here is a super
spreader let's make it happen baby
genius pray every sundays at 12 p.m
oh [ __ ]
you